bonjour david guez
bonjour
et merci beaucoup à vous d'être présent
en direct dans la matinale de france
pour parler de ce nouveau bras de fer
puisque la cour constitutionnelle
polonaise doit trancher sur la primauté
du droit européen sur le droit polonais
à vous votre année on en est où que
va-t-il se passer et quelles
conséquences évidemment s'il a le droit
polonais prime sur le droit européen
c'est très difficile à dire jusqu'à
maintenant le gouvernement polonais est
actuellement aussi la la cour
constitutionnelle en d'essayer de jouer
sur le temps parce qu en effet la
pologne est très dépendante actuellement
des aides aux coraux de hauconcourt on à
virus et donc ne veut pas encore se
brouiller avec l'union européenne
jusqu'à maintenant aussi moravia skill
un premier ministre avait annoncé
également certaines retouches aux
réformes juridiques mais apparemment
cela n'a pas suffi à l'union européenne
et donc c'est aujourd'hui que devra
tomber une décision fondamentale est-ce
que la pologne décidera que la cour
européenne de justice est passée outre
ses propres
pouvoirs ultra vires s ou est ce qu'elle
va s'y soumettre ou est ce qu'elle va
proposer ce que moi j'imagine
probablement le plus le public
diplomatique en compromis mais en l'état
actuel c'est très difficile à dire parce
que les répercussions de cette décision
vont être fondamental non selon ces les
relations entre la pologne et l'union
européenne mais aussi pour l'équilibré
des pouvoirs à l'intérieur on la plaint
condamné lundi à
un demi million d'euros par jour pour
avoir ignoré une ordonnance delà de la
justice européenne elle avait exigé en
mai qu'elle suspende l'activité d'une
mine de charbon un moyen de pression
pour l'union européenne
absolument mais c'est la dure maintenant
depuis des années quand on voit que
l'union européenne un point après
l'autre essaye de mettre la pression sur
la pologne que ce soit sur sa politique
migratoire sur la réforme juridique qui
est en jeu actuellement sur les droits
ou que tout sur la place de l'idéologie
lgbt kyo sur l'avortement maintenant sur
l'exploitation minière de tour of
bientôt probablement sur la centrale
nucléaire que la pologne compte
construire en voit vraiment une
tentative de trouver des endroits où des
lieux des dissensions pour mettre sous
pression la pologne de plus en plus
financièrement aussi et le but le but
est évident le but c'est vraiment de
créer à l'intérieur de la pologne même
un mouvement de plus en plus anti
gouvernementales pour assurer l'élection
dans leur casque comme nouveau nouveau
premier ministre aux prochaines
élections si c'est évident qu'il s'agit
là d'une déstabilisation politique que
l'union européenne et ses idéaux
d'ailleurs avec d'autres moyens
actuellement en hongrie où aussi la très
prochainement les prochaines élections
vont aussi décider du futur politique de
cette nation est aussi de la carrière
politique
ghorbal drone est vraiment là dans une
lutte extrêmement politisée donc pour
vous c'est ce sont des pressions
politiques de la part de bruxelles
comment est-ce que c'est perçu en
pologne qui parlent d'ingérence
finalement intolérable de l'union
européenne dans les affaires intérieures
de la pologne comment est-ce que c'est
perçu par la population polonaise
est bien le but escompté par l'union
européenne
fonctionne dans certains points de vue
on a une polarisation de plus en plus
grande à l'intérieur de la population
européenne
polonaise il faut savoir que la pologne
est extrêmement désireuse de continuer à
faire partie de l'union européenne il ya
vraiment une volonté très forte de faire
partie à nouveau de cet occident
tellement tellement et dialysés et donc
vous avez évidemment une je dirais
majorité de la population qui veut part
peut-être pas par tous les moyens mais
en tout cas autant que possible restez à
l'intérieur de cette union européenne
mais vous avez aussi une certaine
radicalisation à l'intér des
conservateurs et là je remarque quand
même depuis quelques années un certain
changement de discours aussi parmi les
intellectuels du pays qui face à cette
pression là deviennent de plus en plus
sceptique concernant le futur de la
pologne à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et on appelle ou pour nexity
alors ce pôle excite reste actuellement
une option absolument minoritaires et la
longue histoire de la pologne lui a
appris aussi que
voilà une pologne qui se retrouverait
tout seul entre à gauche un bloc
européen dominé plus ou moins vers
berlin et de l'autre côté le système
d'alliances russe n'est pas
nécessairement la meilleure option mais
l'union européenne poussent le pays vers
ce choix là qui est inchangé le
stratégique et politique extrêmement
difficile et qui crée comme je disais
une très forte déstabilisation ici en
nature du pays comment est ce que vous
avez perçu la déclaration michel barnier
qui est l'ancien négociateur du break
site on s'en souvient à vouloir plus de
de souveraineté pour la france en
matière d'immigration notamment il veut
constituer un bouclier constitutionnel
est ce que ça vous donne de l'espoir
c'est difficile à dire j'ai l'impression
que là on est quand même dans une
dans une constellation en europe où il
ne suffit pas que de la surface encore
damon lui fasse la même chose il faut
surtout que les élites de ces différents
pays soient aussi plus voir en accord
les unes avec les autres et c'est pour
ça aussi que toute cette réforme
constitutionnelle polonaise finalement
nacre est né ici en pologne que des
conditions constitutionnelles qui
correspondent déjà à ce que la plupart
des autres nations connaissent
actuellement on reproche à la pologne
une politisation outrancière
du domaine de la justice or toutes les
comparaisons entre le système polonais
nouveau et toute une série d'autres pays
européens notamment d'allemagne ont
montré très bien que la pologne reste
absolument à l'intérieur de ce qui est
visuel dans l'union européenne la seule
différence est évidemment que la
majorité parlementaire polonaise
actuelle est conservatrice et que dès
lors toute nomination
actuel qui serait dans le domaine de la
justice ou des médias autre chose se
fait avec une préférence conservatrice
tout comme dans les autres pays plupart
des autres pays de l'union européenne
elle se fait actuellement avec une
préférence cocistes gauchistes libéral
et c'est ça au fond là la clé du
problème on ne veut permettre une seule
disons démocratisation du système
médiatico juridiques que si elle joue en
faveur des élites libérales et
gauchistes et c'est pour ça que
justement ce genre de déclarations sont
à prendre je crois avec une certaine
distance parce que le problème
fondamental
reste le même on ne permettra finalement
à la pologne de ne faire une politique
nationale si on veut que s'il est fait
par des élites agréé par berlin et dans
une moindre mesure par paris merci
beaucoup david angel pour votre
éclairage je le rappelle vous êtes
historien professeur à l'institut sage
sundi en pologne à l'université libre de
bruxelles